welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens filling in for Eric Voss
while he's out on paternity leave and
this is a breakdown of the trailer for
Fallout a new entry in the video game to
series genre which will hope to
replicate the success of this year's
last of us I'm begging Fallout as a
series with enough nuclear explosions to
make Christopher Nolan look like this so
kick back relax and Munch radroach as we
break down this trailer together this
video will contain spoilers for some of
the Fallout gains so you've been warned
also you should have played the games by
now let's get into
it I know that I've lived a relatively
comfortable
life stop Mercy okay so we open on a
hallway shot inside of Vault 33 Vault 33
is a new Vault created for the show
located outside of Los Angeles near
Santa Monica in the games a multic
conglomerate named vault tech sets up
our vaults as a way to keep the public
safe during times of nuclear fallout but
also as a way to run social experiments
on the inhabitants definitely getting
some Dharma Initiative vibes from this
especially with that appearance from
Michael Emerson this show will take
place in the year 2296 about 219 years
after the nuclear event that turned
Earth into a wasteland so everyone we
meet in the show will be Generations
removed from the nuclear fallout and has
only known this version of survival we
got a shout of our protagonist Lucy
played by Ella Pernell and her Vault
mate as they approach the vault door on
Lucy's left arm is a Pip Boy a wearable
computer issued to every Vault dweller
that monitors vitals stores useful
information about the Wasteland and can
even act as a tape player for all those
times people leave voice recordings
around during the apocalypse you know
that happens during the Apocalypse PHP
as Lucy's Vault mate begs her to stay
notice the body lying on the Vault floor
clearly something changed between Lucy's
approach to the door and it actually
opening the cut on her lip also seems to
imply she had to get into a little
scrape with another Vault dweller in
order to get the door open or perhaps
this is from The Vault 33 Skirmish we
later see in the trailer on to the next
clip you need to go
home Vault dwellers are an endangered
species as Lucy exits the Vault I love
the small Det details the production set
out at the entrance the skull and other
human remains imply that some poor
Survivor likely tried to break into the
Vault or at least camp near the entrance
and hopes that one day they'd be let in
we see a Santa Monica appear and the
Fallout games have been set in SoCal
noal Washington DC New Vegas and Boston
curiously though Santa Monica is a fake
sand beach so I'm wondering if the
nuclear blast has anything to do with
all the sand surrounding this part of
Los Angeles as liy continues to walk
through the rubble notice the bodies
encased in Ash similar to the bodies of
the victims of Mount Vesuvius near
Pompei and let's get on to the next
I do not think you would be willing to
do what it takes to survive up
here if you insist on staying is back
baby we see a shot of radroach entering
a decaying building that Lucy approaches
certainly looking for some kind of loot
perhaps she'll eat her first a radiated
Critter here and have to learn more
about the powers of radway a serum that
could remove radiation from a person in
a scarse resource in the Wasteland Lucy
continues walking and passes what looks
like to me a commercial fishing vessel
considering the crane-like structures at
the bow and stern of the ship likely
further emphasizing the scarcity of food
in this version of Earth Michael Emerson
plays a new character for the show named
will zig I wish I was joking he warns
Lucy about life outside the Vault saying
I do not think you would be willing to
do what it takes to survive a p if you
insist on staying then you will have to
adapt there's a long tradition of
cannibalism in the Fallout Universe it's
possible wizig is speaking about
different undesirable food offerings in
the Wasteland as dog meat devours A rad
roach we have more on dog meat in a
little bit don't worry he's coming up
cannibalism exists in some form in every
Fallout game mostly something practiced
by certain factions of Raiders which I'm
guessing Wilzig is here Wiig is
accompanied by a German Shepherd dog in
the Fallout games you can travel with a
companion often a dog named dog meat dog
meat is a bit like James Bond in that
there is no one dog named dog me dog me
rather is a name for your dog companion
in the games I expect this dog will be
no different I guess Lucy has to kill
will zig early in the series and keep
dog meet until she meets the ghoul who
is often photographed with dog meet and
other promotional photos Okay so in this
clip we Hear n King Kohl's I don't want
to see tomorrow fallouts in-game radio
and its trailers are often accompanied
by music from the cold war time period
most famously The Ink Spot cover of I
don't want to set the world on fire
appears in Fallout 3 Fallout 4 and
Fallout 76 and their track maybe was
featured in the trailer for The Original
Fallout RPG the song's lyrics of
tomorrow so they say will be a lovely
day a bright new sun will suddenly break
through could be in reference here to
the atomic bomb and the brings of a new
dawn to this world another shot shows a
trio of Verte Birds Landing in what I
assume is a Brotherhood of Steel BAS
vertebr were created by the United
States military before the Fallout but
with no US military in existence they've
mostly been co-opted by the Brotherhood
of Steel a faction that spun off from
members of former US military its stated
purpose is to keep up and regulate
pre-war technology in the Wasteland but
like any military body without oversight
hasn't always been as altruistic as they
claim next we meet Maximus played by
Aaron Moten Maximus is a squire to the
BOS member he sits across from who wears
a set of t60 generation power armor
supporting the brother of Steel faction
logo the lettering on the side of the
ver ver bird reads 532 D which is the
designation number for a training
Squadron of the US Air Force Base in
vandenbberg California one shot energy
oh I'll try one I'll try one and if it
doesn't wake me up I'm going to be
[Music]
[Applause]
pissed I know K
[Music]
fu
okay I want to try the focus ones
now
see
eternity okay one shot is really all I
need I think they both clashed in me and
now I don't know where I'm at begin your
transformation with oneshot energy today
by going to oneshot energy.com
new rock stars for 10% off your order I
am going crazy I am an insane person I
have to go see a musical I have to go
sit in a theater oh my
God okay so in this section another shot
shows dog meat carrying a severed hand
and a nod to the games in which you can
have dog meat fetch certain items for
you including various body parts we also
see some blood splatter onto an old juke
box that's situated in a corn field this
cornfield is actually not outside as
later in the trailer we see a new
section of the Vault where some other
agriculture is being tend to seems like
whatever prompts Lucy to leave Vault 33
might be due to Uprising in the
community we also get our glimpse of
Zach Cherry's Vault dweller character
you may recognize Zach from Spider-Man
homecoming shuni or most recently
Severance on Apple TV plus we're big
cheer heads here on new rock stars Lucy
approaches a settlement named Philly
even though it's located in California
is presumably run by Walton goggin's
ghoul character this settlement is
evocative of Megaton in Fallout 3 or
maybe even a smaller version of diamond
City from Fallout 4 the settlement is
made up of scrap sides of shipping
containers a building is made made from
an airplane fuselage and the sign of the
supply shop is falling apart and cobbled
together from various working signs
found around the Wasteland we get our
first look at Walton goggin's ghoul
there are many ghouls in the Fallout
Universe humans that have been exposed
to so much radiation that they've
mutated over time most ghouls become
feral zombie like creatures but there
are some exceptions like goggin's
character here goggin is currently
credited as the ghoul but will likely
have a real name considering ghouls can
live for centuries the ghoul stands in
front of several mannequin heads on
poles these mannequins a definite
presence in the game actually come from
real life doomtown mannequins they were
set up in fake neighborhoods running
nuclear tests to discover the effects of
radiation on humans God next
clip I grabbed a moldy one all right
first we have a sett growing what looks
like Tes doesn't look like he's having
too much success ghoul fights off some
invading Raiders in Philly then we meet
Chris parnell's overseer character this
is a different Vault than Vault 33 you
can see in the background it looks a bit
cleaner and better kept up as we
mentioned earlier vault tech has a
history of experimenting on out dwellers
the overseer Cyclops look is likely an
effect of the experimentation okay so in
this clip we see a turret firing on
someone with a sign please remain calm
the type of Bleak humor found in the
games which will certainly make its way
to the TV show one team would beat the
other team to death with these things
called baseball bats and and the best
bats were called swaters true fact look
dumbass that's not how baseball was
played the person running from the
turret is wearing a lab coat and has dog
meat on a leash running through the
snowy landscape it's possible this is
Wiig in a flashback as series show name
Jonah Nolan has referred to wizig as a
researcher in the past Dairy fresh is an
ice cream manufacturer original to this
show in the foreground a Mr handy robot
or perhaps its variation Dr handy Wheels
a vot dweller possibly Lucy anager we
get our first look at Kyle McLaughlin's
overseer character Hank Hank is the
Overseer in Vault 33 and Lucy's father
he also has a son named Norm who will be
played by Moises Aras I'm so sorry if I
butchered that I think I got it the shot
is likely after Lucy decides to leave
trapping her father behind her we see a
yaai take down someone in power armor
yau are mutated black bears named after
fictional Chinese and tournament camps
set up during fallout's Great War yagai
is Mandarin for demon or Monster and
they are truly some of the most vicious
beasts in the Wasteland perhaps second
only to death claw now we get one of the
most curious shots in the trailer a
woman in a Blazer runs away from what
appears to be a campfire cooking station
carrying a mysterious case in the
distance is like an old house and some
kind of Bunker structure this doesn't
look like any of the other houses we've
seen so far in the trailer not sure
what's going on here if you have any
thoughts please leave a comment let me
know we also get a look at a new
creature that looks like a mix between
an axel and a gulper from The Fallout
games inside its mouth are these like
finger like appendages and I hate them
it's horrible I actually kind of like it
this better not awaken anything in me
Annabelle oh haggen's character Steph
takes shots during the same Vault 33
Uprising with a fork in her eye G Jesus
we also get a shot of another
Brotherhood base with several vertebres
including one that looks like it may
have recently crashed the big Airship up
there is reminiscent of the Airship from
Fallout 4 also on the tarmac there are
what looks to be Tales of some kind of
bomb are the Brotherhood up to something
are they preparing for a new war okay
and here we have a flashback to the year
2077 when the bombs began to drop a
non-mutated Walton goggin hops into his
horse with presumably his daughter as
buildings fall in the background note
that the color of their cowboy costumes
is the same blue and gold as the Vault
jumpsuits given to the Vault dwellers in
a wide shot we see the two ride toward
the blast with the Griffith Observatory
in the foreground here the largest bomb
is a direct hit on downtown LA which any
Angelina will tell you nothing of value
was lost absolutely not a single thing
of value was lost not even me we also
see a vault tech billboard featuring
Vault boy that reads prepare for the
future so what do we think of this
trailer somehow it felt like incomplete
without a war war never changes but I
truly can't wait for this to drop April
12th it looks so fun follow me on
Instagram and Twitter Lulu Clemens
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
go watch this trailer again it's
magnificent bye
[Music]
n